[Music]
you have a son son a daughter and a
daughter and a daughter that going Oh
socks
no it's great
it's fun it also sucks yeah it's
terrible it's just like it is so much
more real and you said the bad one
oh they're both real it's it's
beautifully amazing but you're doing it
for someone else and therefore it's like
socks boring he's getting nothing out of
it
you deserve this game you just have this
thing that was more yeah almost exit
yeah my every need yeah basically of
little Gandolfini's and my kids are a
large weight as was I where you okay
yeah yeah
big ol baby big old fatty there's a
picture of me like nine months where I
am clutching an apple holy I like my
hand is wrapped around the whole thing
you couldn't take that Apple from that
baby no no no and like clearly they
tried to take the picture like someone
was like just just put down the Apple
and I was
[Applause]
[Music]
kindly yeah the only thing better would
be like a turkey leg bar before the
Apple was in my mouth like a cartoon
meal any parent that has not thought
about killing their child he's a liar
because he probably thought about
killing me yesterday you're sleep
deprived you which makes you insane like
the baby doesn't know what's wrong with
it there's stomach hurts they're gassy
they they need a bottle they're hungry
they're tired they you don't know how to
express that the teeth hurt there yeah
babies cry a million times a day and and
you know you get to like your fourth
month where every day has been that with
no brakes and you're holding it in
you're you're like my I throw this thing
out the window I throw this thing out
the window yeah and I'll walk away just
get in my car drive away start a new
life I've talked about a million times
yeah I pull as much as I can out of my
checking account two tickets to paradise
on there ready yeah all of a sudden I'll
be a San Antonio Spurs fan that's it now
I like run like a head shop on the
Riverwalk in San Antonio you know what I
sleep great
me and my Native American wife stitching
dreamcatchers yeah I pretend I'm nude
like so no zip a tag just constantly
giving people directions Riverwalk that
one go now to the river Walker said so
many things I don't know if I can laugh
at
[Music]